digamos que aquí tengo 5 limones 1 2 3 4
5 deliciosos limones mi pregunta es por
qué tengo que multiplicar el 5 para
obtener un 1 o en este caso porque tengo
que multiplicar 5 para obtener un limón
otra forma de verlo es dado que la
multiplicación y la división son dos
caras de la misma moneda entre que
tendría que dividir este 5 para tener de
resultado un 1 un limón o uno de estos
circuitos que dibujé aquí
bueno si tenemos cinco cosas y lo
dividimos en tres cinco vamos a tener
cinco grupos de uno si debido a que
estos limones en cinco grupos voy a
tener grupos con un solo limón 5 entre 5
es igual a 1 o podemos decir que 5 x 1
entre 5 nos va a dar uno también puede
decir que 5 por un quinto es igual a 1
todo esto expresa lo mismo y lo que es
interesante aunque no es un gran
conocimiento es una manera diferente de
expresar algo que ustedes probablemente
ya conocen es la idea de que si yo tengo
un número y lo multiplicó por su inverso
multiplicativo en general cuando la
gente habla de inversos en matemáticas
se refieren a inversos multiplicativos
entonces el resultado va a ser igual a 1
en este caso es porque 5 x un quinto es
lo mismo que 5 dividido entre 5 para
verificarlo tomamos el 5 x 1
que esto es igual a 5 entre 1 x 1 entre
5 hacemos la multiplicación 5 por 1
igual a 5 1 por 5 igual a 5 y nos queda
5 entre 5 que esto es igual a 1
digamos que alguien llega con ustedes y
les dice oye yo tengo este número tengo
el 217 y lo quiero multiplicar por algo
que me dé como resultado un 1 y ustedes
pueden decir bueno si yo toma el 217 y
lo divido entre 217 me va a dar 1 que es
lo mismo que tomar el 217 y
multiplicarlo por 1 entre 217 que es su
inverso multiplicativo una palabra que
es un poco más elegante que lo que es
realmente su concepto pues sólo es
multiplicar por el inverso
de este número otra forma de ver esto es
que si yo tengo 5 cosas y tomó un quinto
con cuántas cosas me voy a quedar bueno
si yo tomo un quinto de 5 me voy a
quedar con una como ven la idea general
es tremendamente simple si yo tuviera un
número bien loco
8 millones 345 mil 271 si quiero saber
multiplicar algo por esto de manera que
aquí hago un producto cruz si lo
multiplicó por algo y quiero obtener un
voy a multiplicarlo por su inverso
multiplicativo 1 entre 8 millones 345
mil 271